[Music]
yes
right
i'll open the meeting
we have an apology from wendy somebody
move and second that
you receive that apology please
thomas singer ray all in favor
yentz kerry thank you
public forum
there isn't any public forum
okay
right conflicts of interest
surely
right
all right thank you
so any other conflicts and interests
that have popped back in your head
all right confirmation of the minutes of
the oxford ohio community board from the
8th of october 2021
somebody moved that they'd be signed as
a correct record please
thomas sing it up
nikki thank you all in favor
gents carried thank you mata's rising
none
reputations and presentations there are
none no
recommendation for speed limit
um good evening everyone
so i'm here to present the report on
with an update on the speed limit
proposed changes
and this is following the
obviously previous approval by the board
to go out and consult on speed limits
earlier in 2021
so we've been through a public
consultation process which went from the
27th of september through to the 18th of
october
and the results of that are included
within this report
just of note we did have 297
submitters providing information
sorry the feedback on the proposal they
didn't submit on all of the often the
full suite of proposed changes
but did comment on obviously areas of
interest to them in particular
we've also been through the process of
seeking feedback from other key
stakeholders such as the police of
wakakotahi
various other organizations
and have included within table one and
two of the recommendation the proposed
speed limits
for the board to consider
and one thing i will note is main street
oxford so the proposed 40 kilometer an
hour speed uh reduction there is subject
to council consideration of budget
through the annual plan process
so that we can implement the traffic
coming which would be required
to achieve that speed
generally for oxford and ohoka
the proposed
changes were well supported
and you can see that in this survey
information
and also just a note while it's not
within the board's area but it is
obvious of interest for the board
the lower end of tram road at 80
kilometers an hour was also well
supported
so i'm happy to take any specific
questions that anyone might have
just like clarification first
um where it says the assessed
safe and appropriate speed and the mega
maps is the nzta's um tool for a csun
what's the how's the manual one worked
out
so mega maps is just one tool that kind
of that we compare
the the actual speed that's calculated
with
with the manual process
there's quite a number of criteria that
we that are sort of set out quite
clearly in the
setting of speed limit rules that we
need to assess each road on and that's a
process that ali has gone through with
looking at takes into a whole
consideration a whole load of things the
number of vehicle crossings proximity of
any hazards the number of intersections
the personal and collective risk so
that's all put into a calculation
which is um then comes up with the
manually calculated speed
so with the net
negative maps the set that those amounts
here come from ncta or as a customer
no mega maps is an nzta tool
um
and it is just that it is a tool that we
use as a sensibility check yes yeah we
do
um just wondering with i totally
understand that the oxford main street
has to come with traffic calming
measures but i wasn't near that um speed
bumps or raised pedestrian crossings
would be a thing do you think that just
because of the type of traffic that does
travel down there that probably wouldn't
be the best
solution just in terms of noise at night
time and
what i would say with that is
raise platforms could be a thing they
don't necessarily have to be
the
what is implemented and what we would
want to go through is with the community
border process of looking at what the
different options are and then looking
at implementing that so i what i've got
at the moment is is ali looking at what
the various options are for trying to
get the speed reduction that we need
through that full length
and then we would come back to the board
on what that might look like
so with your agreement
[Music]
thank you um just a question around the
promotion of the
consultation how was how were the a5
flyers distributed because i didn't
receive one
um my parents who live on ashford road
didn't receive one and i've spoken to at
least five other people who didn't
receive them in oxford so
um it just concerns me that a number of
these people didn't even know what was
going on
um
and i think it's sort of reflected in
the
not even two percent of people in our
area responded to the
consultation
and i
sort of struggled to look at that and
actually make a decision on the
consultation when it's such a small
sample size
yep i can provide feedback on that um
the flyers were delivered um in areas
and i'd have to double check oxford and
where they were and weren't delivered
sorry i don't have that information in
front of me
but they were delivered
in some key affected areas um now those
areas were agreed with our comms
engagement team
so they were i believe some of them were
done through the rural mail
and then i'm
not sure how the rest were delivered so
i will have to follow that out
we also did advertising in the newspaper
we put information on our website we
pushed it out through facebook we had
flyers and information at all of those
service centers just to try and get it
in front of as many people as possible
i know it's quite a big area that we've
covered this time but i guess to provide
a little bit of context around the level
of feedback we normally get
when we did the main north road uh in
bottom of tram road which if you
remember we did the 60
down there
we had 47 submissions so
numbers are not generally really high
and i think we
given we've also been
in overtime so we haven't been able to
do the drop-in sessions
as we would have liked to have
we've we still feel like we have got
some reasonable reach
sorry
um
i'm just going to talk about uh
commercial road
um nzta have recommended that all the
commercial road be um
and the adjacent streets be 40
kilometers per hour
and you've gone with 60 because the
reason is that'll be easier to get it
across to the residence
no one from commercial road
i don't think actually got a flyer
and you've got no feedback from them
so why not do the whole of
of it to 40 kilometers now rather than
wait for your speed management plan
i've been right through all of the
feedbacks and right beside it whether it
was main street um high street weld
street etc
but that no one's commission commented
on commercial roads
but even before you consulted it was
recommended by nzta that it be 40.
when you go out for consultation in the
annual plan
is there any way that area can be
extended
the reason we've gone from burnett
street to bay road is because that is
where all the activity a large portion
of the activity in terms of people
moving between shops and the library
service centre
and the various different places are so
we have we start to have issues you have
minimum lengths of a speed restriction
um and at 50 kilometers an hour that's
500 meters and we've had a look at where
that would fall
with the entrance into oxford
and you end up not being able to push it
far enough out
and i think we we do need to remember
where the activity is actually occurring
and the majority of it is is where those
businesses are which is why our
recommendation to the board is burnett
street to bay road
but you're not really
answering my question when you go out
for the annual plan
can and consultation and and people want
it a bit out further
because it does
yeah
can it be
altered so no it has to go through this
consultations process for speed limits
so that is that's the process we have to
follow when we set speed limits is we
have to go out and consult and if we
wanted to go and change that now we
would have to consult again it's a
little bit like the commercial road a
situation where if we wanted to change
that we would have to go back out and
consult on a different speed limit
so we put a proposal in front of the
community as part of this
the annual plan will cover the funding
side of things but not the speed limit
so we would have to
decouple the two of those
thank you um this is a two i've got two
questions um so we're talking about main
road main street um when you say from
burnett street to bay road there are
pedestrian crossings on both of those
intersections obviously so are we
talking about moving it 20 meters before
those pedestrian crossings or how would
that work
yeah we would certainly look to have
them just all before the pedestrian
crossings
to make sure we have kind of got that
lower speed at or near the pedestrian
crossings
and then it's a matter of what the
pedestrian crossings look like whether
they're raised whether they're not
whatever else we do to try and get that
speed limit reduction as people come up
to that to their point
yeah because the reason i asked that
question is because
um
as you're aware there's a coming coming
heading west there's a
like a garden
like jut out that there have been issues
in the past with the like the plants
growing up and meeting the trees so it's
sort of like a wall and if it was on the
other side of that it's you're not gonna
be able to see it um so we're sort of
talking about having to move at like 30
or 40 meters is that going to be covered
under this consultation or would that
have to be sent back out for more
consultation because it's going to be
further back or
and like we're potentially talking about
changing the nature of the road so would
that change it again and that would that
affect the
this consultation being redundant or
um there is a little bit of leeway in
around in the uh
the position the location of speed limit
signs
that what is
implemented needs to be within about 20
metres of
what is proposed so
we do have i guess a little bit of
leeway to be able to move those
backwards or forwards but if there was a
significant change then we would need to
go through a process of updating that so
if you're talking moving it an extra 40
meters down the road
then yes we would need to adjust that
okay so the second question is um
uh looking down this big table of all
the all the speeds um like the majority
of them the main operating speeds are
pretty close to the proposed
speed limit um and they're pretty close
to the mega maps and the manually
assessed ones
apart from actually gorge road where
it's 20 the main operating speeds is 20
to 24 kilometers above the proposed
speed limit
um just wondering how that
works with the
criteria that it has to be five percent
a maximum above five percent above the
proposed speed limit
that's right
good threshold signs and markings and
where that's
just reinforce that speed
um what we can also do is
[Music]
is
um
yeah it's just because it's all it's
also an
interesting one because like they're
talking about moving it to the north
side of the s bends like you're going to
get pretty good compliance around the
espn's and through the
like the sales road somerset drive down
the hill but then it opens back up and
you've got like 500 metres of perfectly
straight wide country road with no
houses either side
so i just yeah i'm just worried about
how appropriate as it is for that
stretch of the road if you understand
what i mean i'm not sure if you're
familiar with it but
not really an objection but i'm just
concerned that um
the mean operating speed is okay to
be you know the criteria to be broken in
some instances and in other instances
not there doesn't seem to be a lot of
consistency
um i think my
dis
observation with this is
um
just because you don't live on that part
of that road doesn't mean you don't have
an investment in that road
um and by just giving out pamphlets to
people that live on that road you can
get a biased
view of it because of course someone
that lives there or wants something
reduced
but people that commute down that road
may not want it reduced so i just
i don't know i feel like it could quite
easily get skewed the
information they get back because of
whoever is passionate about something
and whoever would if they knew a bit
more then maybe they would
[Music]
be a bit more invested in it and i think
that tram road for instance is
a huge investment in this board as well
not just the um
kai boy board so
i would like to
know that we would have a bit more
input in that road as well because
that's a road that is our arterial route
into
anywhere or any of those other bits that
connect the connected communities to
other places
my understanding and this has been
discussion at previous
community board meetings is
it's not something that i guess you can
recommend on because it is
not within your ward area but i
understand you can note either support
or not for
a particular
speed limit and that could be noted as
part of this
and then that information would go
through to council as part of their
consideration
and obviously nikki can also
voice their at that
at their council meeting
that's helpful
three you mr two person the
recommendation
on page two in the summary agenda
can i just make an amendment to that
recommendation unfortunately
you will note that the right
recommendation is in the report but the
it wasn't copied in the summary agenda
it see it should say
that the hoaxer
oxford or hoka community board receives
the report in a and in b
that
it recommends to cancel
that the following speed
changes listed in a and b below
be approved
because
the board does not have
the authority to approve it the board
will only recommend to council
move that we receive the report and
pass on the recommendation please
ray seconder
mark all in favor
against that people
in main street didn't get the brochure
people in the commercial road
brochure people in bay road didn't get
the brochure and it was all within this
area
yeah okay have some discussion
i was waiting for you to bring that up
moved it marks isn't it
thomas wants some discussion
so do you want
you got anything to say to your motion
you're only then to say to the motions
joanne is it possible to have another
consultation
in oxford
that would
delay the implementation of any speed
limit
changes
if you wanted to go back out to consult
again
and i guess i would just be looking for
confirmation as to what you were wanting
to consult upon
or whether you're wanting general
consultation is obviously quite a
process in doing that
and we have tried to push this out to a
number of different forums obviously
through a number of different medias to
reach people
um
thank you um
i i agree with shirley through his
comments about the um flyer drop um
and i
and just to add to them i i live on park
ave which runs off main street in the
affected area so i would have thought i
would be an affected party so we should
have had one and my parents live on
ashley gorge road
and they're obviously potentially having
it changed three kilometers down the
road from them so i would have thought
it would affect them as well um
and also just
probably more of a general comment
people found it very hard to get a paper
copy of the submission um
that wasn't very available at the
service center i didn't think um and i
think i'm surely mentioned something
along the lines of it to me that
you had to actually ask for it
and if you didn't know about it
you're not going to ask for it obviously
and i'm also concerned about the
the placement of the main road
um burnett street uh
bay road being too tight to the
pedestrian crossings and the
intersections of uh bay road and burnett
street um i think that should have been
extended slightly or something on the
lines of 40 meters from the intersection
or something should have been
included in the consultation
um because i think the guests can have
issues with changing the speed limit so
close to those intersections and the
pedestrian crossings which is where the
issues are
and i think
the main issues are those further the
the end pedestrian crossings as opposed
to
the actual center part so i think
there's going to be issues around that
when the if it is approved in the annual
plan and the traffic calming measures i
have to put in
um i think down the road there's going
to be issues but
that's
and my reason is very very similar
there was
someone in main street who was just out
of the area and she said isn't it good
this is the day before isn't it good
we're going to be 40 kilometers an hour
and we no you're not
you're out of the area just out of the
area and anyhow it's going to cost
nearly half a minute a half million
dollars to get it that way um it didn't
really say in the actual submission
booklet
that there was a
um
that
there was a writer on it
so um and
the advertisement in the papers was
about this big whereas a whole page in
the observer for planning
we didn't
you know there was nothing in our
observer there's lots of elderly people
in oxford who don't have access to the
council's
facebook page or
online
so
and
i know i've been doing this for five
years because i got asked to
you know
my personal opinion is a bit different
but i'm here to um on behalf of the
community and they did want to extend it
a little further and i hear that some of
them
don't want the because of the
noisy trucks at two o'clock in the
morning bumping over the road as it is
now
with um raced
um pedestrians and things like that so
there's got to be some real consultation
with the people
as to what they want
um these people that told me that they
were gonna get they weren't in the area
so they didn't get really a chance and i
pointed it out on a map that's only that
far
so it wasn't really
i don't think the consultation was very
good at all
yeah i know it is um there's a number of
failures including back outside the
police station again and yes it is
programmed for repair i can i'll follow
up and get some timing for you very
aware of the work that needs to be done
[Music]
completely acknowledge and agree and yes
that is very much on our radar
ohio's meeting schedule
up until september
2022.
thank you mr jefferson um
this is the annual report that comes to
the board just set out the dates of the
proposed dates for next year
it is proposed that we
meet at the
oxford town hall or the ohio community
hall you will note that in line with
this year i tried this not to put us in
the oahu hall during the winter months
we will be meeting at the mandeville
sports centre in april
and we're hoping to meet in the west
ethan hall in the 2nd of february
because they have a standard booking
from the scouts on wednesday night and
we might just get in here because that
the schools might not have started at
the 2nd of february so
yeah i will take it as rates if there's
any questions i will be happy to answer
just just for the benefit of us not
repeating the
events
of this evening because zumba was meant
to be in here tonight and i caught that
there was an ad
in the local
facebook page you went um
i don't think they got the the message
um i know you're going to conte um to
be in touch with anna but
um
maybe
once we've agreed on these dates
um
i or somebody can get in touch with the
zumba lady to put in her diary as well
because
i don't think there's a really great
communication
there with the bookings
because this has happened to us twice
i think i think the person that's
doing our bookings um for the haul is
trying to hand it over to someone else
so i think there's just a couple gaps
there at the moment so
[Music]
through you mr jefferson the
mandeville sports centre has been booked
out for us for that evening i have
spoken to richard
and i'm hoping that the west earthen
lady will come back to me a sooner
and i will advise you accordingly but we
won't be sharing a venue now
all right
application of the oxford ohio community
board's discretionary grant fund
from first manners from the life
education trust canterbury
towards the delivery of healthy herald
program
i'm sorry thank you mr chairperson can i
just make an amendment they requested
477 and not 500
if we could just make that correction on
the report please
i'm sorry
i'm so sorry sir
it's the second one mandeville has
477.
they have i'm very sorry about the
confusion
i'll move that we give
the life education program 500
so you're gonna
write any disclashing
all in favor
against
harry thank you
all right
and
a grant to the mandeville sports club
for 477
towards the purchase of life members
board for the club
shirley is moving secondly by
nikki
in the discussion
all in favor
against herod thank you
that's 477.
and approves the grant to the
eaton pony club towards the cost of
building horse yards
sorry
through you mr jefferson the concern has
been raised that the horse yards may be
considered
buildings
and you will look
in
the correct board criteria
that it says the board will not consider
the purchase of buildings or
property
so
the criteria is a guideline if if the
board wishes to grant them
the 500 they more than welcome but that
just should be taken into consideration
these are horse yards the club's
building which are not yards that you'll
move around every weekend they're not 90
odd yards that'll be
post will be probably concreted in and
made up and they'll be there for 10 15
20 years so they're a permanent
structure
you know and and the yards are costing
us
41 000 dollars to build them so
almost like the cost of a shed so i
raise the query
through as uh
as a gray line whether or not is it
considered to be a building because it's
a permanent structure
yeah i just want a clarification for the
board
i built cattle yards on my property
several years ago and there's no way
that that's a building
so
if you look at the criteria it says
we do not support the purchase of land
and buildings and i've always
interpreted that that we do not buy real
estate
but um
then mark raised the question of a fair
question is this not a permanent
structure there for a building
but
i don't know i must be honest with you i
don't know
in my experience it's not covered by the
building act as such
i'm not i'm
not against the grounding of the
of it i just thought it was worthy of a
a question because we probably we could
end up getting more someone then comes
and says hey i want to
buy a total span shed that doesn't need
a building consent so
western riding
rodeo putting in a shed that doesn't
need a consent but it's a three-sided
shed with a garage door on the front
where we give them 500 dollars for that
building
you know that's the that's the sort of
things we're getting i think we're going
to get more requests off so
to ray's point that doesn't have a
consent
and that that building doesn't need to
consent from the house because it's
small enough so um is it because it's an
asset becomes an asset to the club
is that what the point is is that you're
providing them funds for them
an asset
i don't know i'm i'm just trying to
figure out why why a building's
different to anything else
if the club's got
jumps out in the
arena
they're an asset
but i'm sure they're not a building
if we like we can um table
the application and maybe
talk to the people in the building
department and see if it is considered
building or not considered building and
what would be required
i'd be been in touch some time ago with
the waimakari public arts trust
and asked them what we did to get a
mural on the toilets
they weren't quite sure
and said just give a give a design and
they would either approve it or not
i had contacted the green spaces
and he advised me that they um there was
no
um policy on murals for public toilets
but um
this has been going on for about six
years and
kpop so beautiful would really like to
move it on
and the only way we can move it on is
actually
find out from the council what
we
as oxford promotions group
and kpops are beautiful need to do to
get over the line
so
what i had actually written out was a
a recommendation that i can't do
but
we would just like to be able to sit
down with green spaces and say these the
things you can and can't do
to employ or engage
you know local painters volunteers and
artists
so that's all i'm asking really for the
board
to come on board with that really
uh
that we keep a the same but change
shirley farrell to oxford promotions
because the letters from oxford
promotions and shirley just did on
behalf of them
um and then b support the proposed theme
for the mural of native flora and flora
and fauna on the front exterior of the
main street toilets in accordance by
the brief outlined by opec um
c advised council's green space team of
the board's support for the proposed
theme
of the mural of flora native floor in
florina um d request the council's green
space team to liaise with opec and
advise them of the conditions required
by the council to enable them to move
forward
to seeker design and costings for
painters artists and volunteers um and
he notes that a report of with the final
design and costing shall be submitted to
the board for consideration
[Music]
just to clarify i'm just always a bit
confused about the whole situation so
oxford promotions wants to paint a mural
on a public toilet
owned by council
the council
and
there's a problem with that
getting information about how to do that
so shirley probably could give a better
backstory than me but she's got a
conflict um so
about 10 years ago there was a mural on
the toilets the council came and painted
over them without telling anyone
and then so from there ox keeper
beautiful went right we'll put a new one
on it
and for the last six or seven years i've
been getting from the council you've got
to wait until there's a
arts and public places trust
set up to approve a mural so we can't do
anything until that happens
so now it's set up um and shirley's
again and quiet about it
she can't find anything out about it so
basically all we're asking for is green
space to go back and work with them and
figure out what they have to do to do it
it's their offering to organize funding
for it and organize artists and stuff
and to get it painted to get a base coat
painted but they just need the council
to come to the table and
assist them and what they need to do to
do it
so we're not asking for a lot
right so the pearson park and the
actually good advisor groups both aren't
meeting under level two so i haven't
done anything for them so really all
i've been doing for the last month is
just my normal
community trust stuff we had our agm
last week um
again obviously with not many people
there because we're in level two
um
but again they're in a healthy position
and um
they've secured ongoing funding to
continue
into the future so they're in a into in
a very healthy position and um
they've maintained their current staff
which are
working incredibly well in the community
and other than that
the
green spaces have actually re-sown and
leveled out the farmers market area in
peace and parks and it's looking good so
hopefully i'll better use it soon
um it was quite bumpy and the grass was
the patchy survey yeah re-sowed it and
i've i think got mowed for the first
time last week so it's looking good
yeah not much to report this month i
attended the mandeville sports center
delegates meeting a couple of weeks ago
and the
um all boards meeting of last week
and had a very enjoyable friday evening
last week uh taking part in the wdc uh
social club quiz
very lot of fun and we did really well
we did very well
especially with this young lady to my
right
i attended a museum meeting oxford
museum meeting uh nothing really to
report other than a they said in an
incognito health and safety officer came
in and
then they were told that they needed to
secure a lot of stuff
along the walls uh one thing i did
attend i got asked to attend was the
oxford amp association
meeting that they had with two of our
planners
regarding what is in the new proposed
plan
um
they are
zoned residential
and
they've done the amp show for like 150
years or something
but
now they it's going to have permitted
activities which means they it will be
limited in some aspects
um
just like
um it doesn't say they have helicopter
landings with um you know when someone's
injured and things like that that's not
in their permitted activities they're
really concerned about the uh
the lighting for the observatory
because there's nothing in there the uh
rugby club actually have the big lights
going sometimes um twice a week during
the winter there's nothing in there to
say it it says that there should be no
lights at
x amount of time in some other part of
it
um they
a lot of people when they have the uh
annual show
people come with caravans and everything
like that and they stay on the grounds
for a couple of days with their horses
and that it said that they can't do that
if there's a residential activity in the
on the grounds at the same time
they're not allowed grazing
that excludes the use of land and
buildings for keeping and grazing when
there is residential activity so
that that won't be able to be done they
do have rv people come and
and stay and use their um facilities
so they're really concerned about
how it's going and i'm just wondering
can the community board support
a submission to say that
they are permitted to use the building
the grounds as they've done in the past
i don't think they've ever had a
complaint about what is going on
in their
grounds you might be able to
so my understanding is the zoning is
changing from residential to there
they're putting the overlay on at the
open sp right
so
um certainly my understanding was it
would not restrict those things but so
at the meeting who attended the meeting
with um
johnson oh yeah
yep yep so um
if that's if
i mean that it has to be done through
submission so that's the only way that
that can be put in so if they've got
concerns that
that they're going to have more
restricted provisions under that overlay
then it's just a submission through to
the um district plan review and then
that will be considered yeah i realize
that yeah
not to be
approved no
but that'll be hearings commissions the
only one who can hear that and make that
decision so that the oxford community
board can certainly on any points in
relation to the district also at its
submission
um but yeah i
look what might be useful is if i get
mac bacon to do a summary of that
meeting and where he believes that got
to to help him form the submission just
to clarify those points because there's
a couple of things from there i find a
bit surprising
the secretary actually asked she found
it like me
very hard to read the implant
and she asked for
the help
and
this
planner said sorry for the delay i'm
trying to work out the best way and
being able to show you how to use it
no that's to try and show you remotely
so um
you look absolutely and we've got people
submitting on paper it's no problem and
we've got people submitting through
e-plan and getting talked through it so
getting submission done is no issue the
cool thing is what do you want to say
any submission so i think step number
one is if i get matt bacon to if he's at
that meeting to clarify
uh the situation the points of concern
and provide some guidance as to how
which elements to bring up in a
submission you won't be able to write
the submission but he can say hey these
are the things
from my understanding that you're
concerned about
and this is what you'd need to submit on
so i can get him to summarise that
and provide that information back to her
to the groups that attended you can
circulate to the community board
if that
that should
clarify
any outstanding matters that you want to
submit on
that there could be something left out
and they go to do an event and it's not
a permitted activity there is also um
the thing that that's new to this plan
though is uh temporary activities so the
great thing about that was we've not had
that provision before is that if there
is something because what we what
council wanted to do is make sure
anything innovative that people want to
do in the future that we may not have
considered now that there's actually
temporary activity provisions so for
example i don't know they might be from
drone flying competitions or or i don't
know
so there is now temporary activity
provisions so that there is an ability
um for events to come under that as well
but certainly you're right the intent
should be that the core activities are
allowed for
um but there is a temporary activities
provision as well
it just seems that they have to list
everything
which what if they missed something out
yes that's right so there's so they've
tried to be broad ranged but the
temporary activities is kind of the
a backup which we've not had before
which we we strike it now so we get
applications on the current plan that
were not envisaged and weren't even
considered and so would would
do trigger resource consent because we
have no temporary activity provisions so
there's a backup but you're absolutely
right step number one make sure the
overlay is as
so what they want to do is make sure the
overlay is as encompassing of what
they're currently doing as possible as
what you're saying
so i think what i can do is ask matt
bacon to summarise that meeting
make really clear the things that
they've raised that they're concerned
they're not going to be able to do make
it really clear whether that is the case
and what they should submit on
so we can certainly provide that
confirmation
thank you i don't know if they've done
that already but it's just that she was
she's very concerned that something so
we can check that and then circulate
surely it could go around the board
happy to do that
um noteworthy things for me as i
attended the opec meeting um
they've got a mixer mingle coming up for
oxford businesses in november from
memory is that right
mix and mimble 15th which is great
um
lions were
at the meeting and they're fundraising
for a new vehicle for the oxford
rural trust from oxford health trust
the rural nurse
um i've got some connections with
mitsubishi so i'm going to see if we can
help them
get a better deal on the vehicle looking
for and we and we had a
what would consider to be a new zealand
famous actress at the meeting
yeah
who's the one from the arts trust
who's the lady from the arts trust
she was in gloss
yeah
no i recognized uh i went home and i
asked my wife and googled her name and
yeah she was a new zealand actress
there's been a lot of new zealand soaps
and so forth so
there you go you learn something every
day
um
since when is not here for the
mendeville board um good news is they
got a grant for the tractor so boards
signed off and buying a brand new
tractor for the grounds person
that's been delivered hopefully next
couple of weeks
and the club as you know is
looking at redevelopment of club rooms
version two of the concept went out to
all clubs we got about 43 items of
feedback which have now been collated
and sent back to the board for for
consideration for version three
of that plan so
and my last point is that the bane of
every lifestyle block owner at this time
of year coming up will be
guy fawkes night
so spend most night outside with torches
trying to and wire cutters just
for horses and cattle that will go
through fences so
yeah so that is banned the better
[Music]
right um
on the 19th of october i attended a
meeting
with sandona residents
that
ray had organised with a couple of
planners that was very interesting and
good to see
a majority of the residents from there
there supporting the fact that they
would like the growth in our area to be
in their area so
if um if we did as a board think that
was a an area that made sense it seems
like
the locals think it does so
it's a sort of
reaffirms
the logic and that
um
on the 27th went to the all boards
meeting as well and then yesterday we
had
a
wag meeting via teams
not a nice platform but anyway
and there's just a couple of things
through that just that obviously gps are
extremely busy
they are lacking staff because they
can't get any staff in the country
seems to be the problem um
lots of great food security projects
nine new food forests are going to pop
up around the communities with um brent
can sort of pushing those along which is
really
um great initiative i think one might be
in oxford too is it i think maybe
um
the next steps coordinator is the
development of the website is going to
be going ahead so connecting people into
services
that they might need to access
there's some art strategy funding coming
up which they're hoping to use for a
broader range of things rather than just
art itself but helping with um
any
mental health and
and well-being
um
there's quite a few people from
gloriavale apparently settling in north
canterbury now so there's been some
meetings of how to make that transition
successful as possible and
there is um the police wanting more
support
from the communities because 70 of their
time at the moment is dealing with
mental health responses
so they are wanting
more community to support
to help with that so they have got
obviously more time to do other things
as well
um and i was also thinking
um
that maybe if i got some information
from the community trust
and how that's tracking along with
things i could feed that back into that
work um meeting thinking when you're
saying about that today thomas so maybe
if you could flick me minutes or
at any
information that comes from that meeting
then i can feed it back into that and
get them updated
i'll just talk about a couple of these
things on here i've emailed
everything's been emailed to you guys
anyway
but i suppose of note in the last month
we had the zone 5 and 6 conference which
i attended it was here in christchurch
and what that is a local government new
zealand
zone 5 and 6 is basically the south
island so zone 5 is the top of the south
island zone six is the bottom so
everybody comes together
in one place every six months
um
and and it was just really reflective of
the fact that there's an awful lot of
upheaval going on right now because
we've got obviously in the shadow of
copen19 we have through waters reform
we've got future for local government
reform we've got resource management
reform there's health board reform
um
then there's the just
discussions around things like housing
and the nzta's you know
nltp funding or not funding
um
a lot of councils around the country
we're very lucky i think that we aren't
so dependent on tourism because
a lot of other areas are really
screaming out because
you know they've really lost their bread
and butter so we're very fortunate in
that effect that we don't have our eggs
in that basket
but yeah it was
it's always a really good chance to get
together and network and just sort of
see what's going on out there and i have
to say that
our
our council is i think doing a heck of a
lot better than than our
our neighbors
as far as
how their economic um
bounce back is going or or in their
welfare i think um just in the shadow of
covet and everything else that's going
on so um
but yeah there's there's an awful lot of
about people out there
uh the district planning and regulation
committee meeting um i suppose things of
note there
that our um resource consents are
significantly up from 2020 and trending
upwards your team would corroborate that
wouldn't they tracy
but 98 of them are still being processed
on time
so that's pretty darn good i think there
are only four that didn't quite squeak
in um under the statutory time limit so
um and we're waiting to see if the the
dp notification
or the resource management
reform um is going to affect our numbers
um
that's just uh how long will a piece of
string be but so far so good touchwood
our environmental services unit um has
also reported back to us there's been a
growth in dog numbers
you know everybody talks about dogs and
and not being on leashes and not being
picked up after and whatever but um dare
i say it 94 of them have at least gotten
themselves registered and um council's
in contact with the other six that
didn't so
that can't be too bad um
the
online services are becoming a more
prominent feature of of our offering
they're able to for instance you know do
say dog licensing online and i think
they're they're hoping to be able to
roll those things out in other
departments as well so it'll be really
good to see what kind of
online processing abilities that we
might be able to do in future but we'll
just see and does that
make sense with you yep and
i i look at tracy because this is
actually her apartment i'm talking about
so um
and the end over lockdown as we've also
all heard and seen on our local social
media and from our neighbors and that
there was a rise in litter and noise
service requests um
over you know most likely linked to the
lockdown um because you know people were
out and about noticing things a bit more
and obviously they were they were all at
home and
um so
yeah
yes you received 232 more service
requests than they did last year so
that's a pretty reasonable um
extra chunk of time
and as wendy's not here i'll just talk
about the community recreation
committee meeting
probably things of note there that
neighborhood support
asked council to divert their 3200 200
funding from the community barbecues to
growing the membership because they've
been making a concerted effort to
actually expand their membership and
they thought that it was actually better
for them to be able to use that funding
to
get out into the communities and talk to
people about neighborhood support and
gets ready rather than spend all their
money on barbecues around the place but
council will still um
support that by carrying on the
community barbecues in in their stead so
it will be good to sort of see those
things still happen because i know for
instance the one that we we've held in
ohoka here for the last few years has
been very well attended
um and they've been really great events
so you know i'd hate to see them stop
happening so it's good to
see that we can all have our cake and
eat it too in that respect um
our library team
they are all stars i don't know if you
guys go to the libraries that much i
know you do
but our library team are absolutely
amazing and um they always make me happy
whenever they make whenever they do
reports but
the their latest was that they took
fourth place in a global library song
contest for down at your local library
fourth place in the world
i don't know if we can you know make
signs for that or claim to fame or what
but you know hey i'm i'm gonna run with
that because again that that puts a
smile on my face i hope it does yours
too
um they are also looking at um growing
their social media sort of footprint and
um and they're seeing um
growth in
desire for different um
different social media i suppose for
reaching different audiences and whatnot
so that's kind of interesting
see where they get with that um
the
with the pools cover 19 of course isn't
impacting
their visitor levels as they do
everywhere else but i
i i think that um they are still coping
remarkably well given that um you know
they're they're stretched in some other
capacities and um they're just kind of
making the most of
a tough time but people are actually
quite enjoying the chance to um get in
and book lane space so they know that
whenever because they've got a booking
they know that whenever they go they're
going to have their swimming lane and
they're not going to have to share it
with 14 other people or whatever so
at least you know that's going well
but
[Music]
and with
regard to the green space 21 22 work
plan you'll all be interested to know
that the rifle club
ongoing options are being investigated
again that's a really tough one the um
because of the lead that they still use
in their shot so it's kind of really
difficult it's proven very difficult to
find a new home for them because i've
had to move from cust
and they're hoping to maybe find
someplace because i think they started
out in oxford didn't they
the rifle club nine two two two
different clubs two different okay
another one was oxford okay and so they
merged
no they okay oxfords went into well
recess and then they could they wanted
to go to start again but they couldn't
because the building has been
strengthened and the rifle range has
been used the giant concrete pillar in
the middle of the ring oh right
yeah well so this this one
for the the cust
club which i think is called
yeah um
anyway
it's
proving difficult for them to find a new
home but they haven't given up on them
but i mean if if anybody knows any uh
has any good ideas of where we can house
them that'd be great but
um
anyway moving right along the west
oxford toilets tender has closed
i presume because it was supposed to
close the end of october which of course
was a few days ago so that will be a
watch this space
hopefully we'll get that underway
shortly and the cooper's creek toilet is
a collaboration with doc and um
so
and that's the one i believe that has no
west oxford is the one that actually got
national funding for tourism
infrastructure
is that right yeah
but hey two new toilets in west oxford
and cooper's creek
on the way so
um and the wolf's road suspension bridge
surely
they've engaged a consultant and they
are
looking to consult the public by
february 2022 so
early next year
is the plan for that so again
you know notwithstanding
whatever mother earth or
diseases or whatever else we want to
throw our way that is our plan anyhow so
fingers crossed we get that underway
yeah i know
honestly like
are we waiting for locusts because i am
you know a plague of locusts because
we've had you know earthquakes and
floods and
pestilence and you know it's like crying
out loud okay i shouldn't speak that
into existence um
on the 21st of october i had a marvelous
day going out to view hill school who
did a planting day in conjunction with
working waters trust
out on the
neighboring farm kofi farm
to enhance the habitat of the cold water
the mudfish i had never seen a mud fish
i have seen a mud fish now it was quite
exciting
but
the kids and the volunteers they're
awesome and um they got the job done and
it was yeah really really lovely to
finally go out and attend a planting day
in my own ward hallelujah because
i'll go to a planting day anywhere so
it's really nice to actually see some
stuff going on in our own backyard so
that was really cool and
over the last weekend we just had the
training days for the flamingo e-scooter
launch
which i had to turn up on one of those
because i have to say for all my
enthusiasm about e-scooters i had never
ridden one before so
i can say that i've done that now and it
wasn't nearly as hard as i thought so
if you get the chance have a go
and
council meeting i can't say was
um probably had a whole lot of exciting
things from the board's point of view in
there um the representation review
decision
we
as you would be aware
went ahead with the status quo except
for the amrengara ashley community board
area where they're changing from what
was kind of five urban and three rural
subdivision to
six members
urban and two rural just to reflect the
population balance
and
yeah that's about it really
any questions
[Music]
t has a question
what
what does a mud fish look like
is it a flat fish
no they um actually there might be a
photo i can show you
[Music]
their little little
honestly they remind me a bit of
tadpoles just before they sprout legs
[Laughter]
yeah yeah can i just comment on that the
first canterbury mudfish was actually
found
on our property that we've got now and
there's actually a mudfish plaque at the
end of bosch road and mill road
mr burrows actually found it
in 1930 something and there was a i
coordinated a mudfish day with the
department of
at department conservation um about
eight years ago and they had mud fish we
had mud wrestling and mud cake and
things like that so yeah very cool so
i've got a t-shirt if you want it
you want a t-shirt
there's a lovely young woman that um
there you go tia there's a picture of a
mudfish
no no
no they're very endangered
what's what's really clever about them
is that yeah so they they can actually
whenever whenever um the streams that
they live in dry up over summer they can
burrow down into the mud when there's no
water and basically hibernate in mud and
that's why they call them mudfish so
they're very clever
um yeah no i wouldn't probably eat one
no
but a young lady that um
i
that volunteered that day she is a
new newly graduating freshwater
ecologist really jazzed on them and she
reckons she's going to get a tattoo of a
mudfish so there you go
i see your t-shirt and i raise you a
tattoo
[Laughter]
so yeah did you have a question sorry
i'm just wondering if you've heard if
the cycle network plan is going out for
submission anytime soon like or is that
being put off again um that was part of
um
we actually tabled two
reports
that came to council yesterday
um and they were to it's a shame that
joanne's not here but um
we're just really trying to see what we
can squeeze out of nzta
um they've they've made a few
adjustments to what they've offered us
[Music]
but it's still unclear but by and large
my understanding is as it stands that we
didn't get any funding for for that
which i find utterly shocking because
they've said focus on things you know
lower emissions activities and pt and
active transport mode shift blah blah so
we did and they gave us no money for it
so
the idea i think was that they would go
and consult for it anyway
in the meantime we'll try to to see if
we can wanker more more funding
but
we will just go to the community with
the half funding that we've got
and
see where it goes from there and just
hope that nzta sees that we have a
shovel ready project ready to roll and
um will come and come to the party
uh it's really disappointing
but um and i and i had but i haven't
given up hope that they'll completely
abandon us
yet
at least not on that that just doesn't
make any sense to me you know they're
telling us to focus on you know
low-carbon
transport and they give us nothing for
it so
i'm just wondering because the um swan
and off school has
started doing quite a lot of work to try
and so when this came out for
consultation they were ready to hit the
ground with promoting it in the
community
um
i'm wondering if
the council might be able to use what
they've done
and what they're planning to do to go to
nzta
is a little uh that was a question the
kids promotion i wanted to ask them
about um
[Music]
about the low-cost low-risk funding
um
and i'm just wrong agenda see if i can
pop it up so
sorry i'm just trying to find some notes
in here um while you're finding it um i
am concerned that the rural area will be
left behind again even with what's
neeted i reckon it'll go to the
eastern part of it whereas you know
looking down the swannanoa area to
mandeville it's not very far the side
roads it would be great if the children
could get on their bikes
and bike to school
but we have to promote it that's
something that that i am absolutely
gonna fight for and and do fight for
every chance i get because it's it's
fine and well for the urban children to
you know be encouraged to
take a bike or whatever but the fact of
the matter is you know they can walk
safely to school probably um whereas our
kids particularly you know royal kids in
that in that
we stretched down there from
downtram road to just want to know a
school those kids fall outside of you
know they're just a little bit too close
to school to get a school bus
but
too far to safely
cycle or walk
it's yeah it's it's not a a safe road to
put a child on a bike on
and um the kids that do sort of live in
that area they they travel a rather
convoluted way so that they can go kind
of off-road through the wii um
walk away between stone air place and
uh weathers field
um anyway some some of the the roads up
there they they have like a little
walkway um where they they connect and
and so that they go you know probably a
good key or whatever out of their way so
they can be safer to bike to school
um
yeah that's that's something that um
yeah i was
wanting to um
push on that um
to see if we could get something
um
at least that particular project through
for the um walking um sorry through the
minor safety program
but um then before i could ask my
question they tabled the report
so i will ask the question next time
but um yeah i think thank you for
letting me know about the support from
the school
all right thank you let's move on
sorry thomas has a question thomas has a
question let's move back
it's actually a question for tia
actually but um can we chase up
some information about the rifle club
situation well i have asked about it
before
various people and this seems to be
i don't know like a secret squirrel sort
of operation going on there but
um because i've asked through pearson
park as well
well
the
rifle club it's the i don't know what
they're calling it now but it's the cast
and the ox rifle club two different
clubs
about both yeah because there's money
being set aside but i sort of don't
really know what they're doing so it'd
be nice to have a bit of an idea
and also our long-term plan submission
response we haven't
heard anything
can we move on now yes
good thank you
consultation projects
proposed district plan
e-scooters
and the draft district parking strategy
any comments
one someone from oxford wants to know
when the scooters are coming to our
streets
right
board funding update
board discretionary grant funders at six
thousand seven hundred and ninety
dollars
that's what we
granted tonight
and the general landscaping fund at
twelve thousand seven hundred and ten
there's no media items no questions
understanding orders nowhere's in
general business
workshop we have anything to workshop no
nothing to worship i just have one
question i emailed everybody a copy of
the first draft of the submission
please
i appreciate any more input that we can
include
and then i can do the final draft and
that forward that to everybody for the
final approval before we have to submit
before the 26th of november
but that's it
tia i did ask some questions um will
they be answered
i have forwarded them to trevor
with a
very high priority sticker on it and as
soon as i get the answers back i will
get that to you so that we can include
some of that stuff in our submission as
well
you